great research again I'm not going to
make a long introduction but just to say
that does the theoretically inclined
person who is not really a card-carrying
member
yes theory community many of us are
always looking and wondering look
waiting for when the cs30 community has
things that are particular interesting
relevant to us we've learned about it
kind of quickly we're always intrigued
and and that happens from time to time
and it often it happens the neighbor
I'll be kind of as associated with any
videos so I'm particularly eager to hear
what you have to say about this topic
which I know he's actually been thinking
about for quite some times by the one
person yes there's communities thank you
very much my guy I hope to live up to
that introduction so thank you for all
of his thing and coming here for the
workshop and it you know sort of
inaugurating this wonderful building and
the Institute which all the folks here I
worked very hard to bring and I think I
should give them a hand before I start
so my talk was sobbing since this is the
last fall kite I'm supposed also since
I'm sort of grown up and supposed to
philosophize a bit but you know I find
myself liking what they call the vision
thing so mostly I'll just to vignette
from things I know which connect up as
Mike said which connect up these various
areas numerical analysis machine
learning statistics as well as what
we've come to call TCS in the last few
decades I mean which is all there's no
clear boundaries but we'll try to
connect up the lot so I I call that so
since I don't have vision I borrowed
some here was a talk that dick cop gave
on the 50th anniversary of Fox's talk
and he said what makes an algorithm
great and I'll ball of this for saying
what makes big data research great now
the color coding is not his I impose my
color coding on that I just simplified
the blue was truth and beauty if you
will the Green was useful the reason I
put this up for big data in particular
is we've heard a lot of mention of how
useful things that we do in the paradigm
of big
but I'd also like to stress that a lot
of the techniques that people have
developed and you've seen over the week
or really do have the other component
truth and beauty as well and we'll
probably see a little bit of that
there's no well it's a wavelength it is
complete frequencies in between oh yeah
I suppose you know it's it's really not
a strict division so their theme the
starting theme of the talk and I like a
couple of pictures of the team is that
why now this is this is not even worth
mentioning because you all know this but
geometry that is viewing vectors viewing
data as vectors turns out to be very
useful even in cases when there are no
vectors in sight when you see the data
and randomness mixed in with linear
algebra that vectors give you linear
algebra randomness mixed in with that
is extremely useful again you've seen
this over the week now generally in
quite often we view data as vectors but
it turns out also to be very useful as
people an optimization have done for
decades now to view solutions as vectors
so for instance if you want to solve a
very large Traveling Salesman problem
what do you do you represent a solution
as a zero one vector in a ungodly number
of dimensions and then somehow it all
works to solve several thousand city
problems those are the champion
solutions but it views the solution as a
vector now you can ask is geometry just
a bookkeeping device and we'll see we
have seen already you all know by now
but I will show you some pictures that
it's not so there should be a real title
of the top much of the material is also
due to john hawk craft the way of
viewing where we have finished writing a
book and which you can download please
it's several hundred pages please don't
print it on at Calvin printing you can
download it and use it any way you like
printed at home but not here right so
several of the things are from that
that's a boat an undergraduate and build
advanced undergraduate and graduate text
that you're free to use okay data is
vectors so okay this is by now more or
less a given
a lot of people's mind but let's quickly
see some aspects before we go to some
brass tracks it's useful to think of it
the departure from traditional stuff is
that or physics if you will is that
these vectors are cite in very high
dimensions right even if there's no
obvious geometry to the data in the
first site now as if it'll depend on
attribute this to one person or whatever
but it is the case that for us in this
setting in information retrieval setting
salt and thought of the vector space
model document two matrices but there
are lots of users in economics and
operations research in computer science
before that of course customer matrices
customer product matrices now here is a
more recent thing alone Mathiason Sogeti
in viewing NetFlow data and trying to
compute frequency moments and i again
this has been covered in the talks i
won't go into detail by they formulated
this as a problem in a very high
dimensional vector space and then
projected it down to get it's like right
there was no vector there it's just
that's the way they formulated it
feature vectors and machine learning all
pretty standard now you all know again
what I want to stress this with some
pictures that the vector notation is not
a data structure of just it's more than
that all kinds of things like our
Authority and singular vectors are very
nice meanings without going into our
detail but I have a couple of nice
pictures from past talks that I thought
I would put up here's one use of
orthogonality if you represent webpages
as vectors let's say you put down
whatever terms occur each term is one
component and you put down how many
times it occurs or some function of it
if you search for the word Jaguar it's
now not the case but it used to be that
you would get mostly the cars if you're
interested in the animal you're sunk now
we saw during this week then if you have
a very large collection of vectors or
very large matrix you sample the rows of
the matrix or if you will you sample
some of the vectors and then process
them one sampling technique that you saw
was using length squared sampling
that is you sample with probability
proportional to the squared length now
if you had 90% Jaguars and they were
much longer you'll never see the animal
if you did this how do you fix this you
saw in the talks a way of fixing this
using leverage course but here's another
simple geometric way of fixing this
problem instead of picking single
vectors with length squared
probabilities let me pick pairs of
vectors with probability proportional to
the area squared it turns out and this
was the square keeps appearing here
that's the truth and beauty component if
you didn't have the square linear
algebra would be in trouble right you
wouldn't get as nice things and in fact
here also you wouldn't get as nice the
results as you did do with the square
but probability proportional to the
squared area of the triangle spanned
that would favor picking one of these in
one of these picking two orthogonal
vectors or nearly orthogonal vectors
because then you get a large area this
is a technique that was used by daesh
pon de Guatemala and Paulo it does many
of the things that leverage goes do but
differently and with different bounds
right now you could have a more serious
problem and this is mostly to thank Mike
or to Alan freeze for a long time so you
could have what's called the freeze
problem or you could have even worse
problems but there are three meanings of
the word freeze the most important one
is this this is Mike all right but he
may not have as many pages on the web as
as the magazine or the architectural
style and here you would want to pick
triples of vectors but probably
proportional to the square of this
volume of the simplicity span and that
turns out to give you very nice
theoretical results this is called
volume sampling I won't tell you more
about it but this is all just to say
that the vectors are there not just for
being data structure but for very useful
things like this geometric things
there's a very nice piece of work by Ben
tasks are usually watching on
determinantal point processes okay could
have exactly a volume interpretation and
have a diversity interpretations of Zeta
analysis that connections in the physics
literature is pretty pretty obvious yeah
so good point this somebody called
manjunath Krishna Poole was also you all
para systems we've also worked on so the
new terminal processing side volume
sampling have been connected up now and
indeed yeah yeah okay so now randomness
yeah if there's a slight distinction
that I want to I want to emphasize as
you all know again that this is true but
either the algorithm all the data can
toss coins what does it mean for the
data to toss coins you have a
probabilistic you have a stochastic
model of data and clearly in statistics
things like mixture models are in long
study in computer science probably in
TCS they cop started in a way the
probabilistic analysis of algorithms on
which they were very nice results
starting from the seventies that's when
the data tosses coins right
the other thing randomized algorithms is
when the algorithm process mines you
have a random number generator built
which the algorithm can use and I call
this a well kept secret weapon of TCS
not anymore for a long time it used to
be in the sense for instance valiant and
Webner had beautiful results on network
routing using randomization load
balancing using randomization and
nearest neighbor which you saw in this
during this week and you saw the results
are Alex president random projections
are very useful for reducing the
dimension quite in practice these things
are not used nearly as much as in theory
even for the nearest neighbor
people use data dependent projections
for instance PCA more so than random
projections whereas in theory use random
projections Network routing again people
are sort of loathe to use randomized
routing tables for a good reason but in
any case if this is not the case it's a
secret weapon anymore it's now it's now
sort of come out in the open and we saw
quite a bit of that during the week
okay so now I come to the bat strikes
bootcamp singular value decomposition
just in case you haven't heard about it
I'm sure all of you have half a slight
description perhaps I want to say that
maybe the perspective is well III should
crack this little joke on statistics and
machine learning why not right
they statistics as for century or so
buried beautiful ideas beautiful ideas
in bad notation and some of machine
learning seems to be inherited this and
I mean I want to try to see if I can
have it I mean this is not my idea
obviously it's it's an all the idea but
there are a lot of ideas in machine
learning like that which you know once
you decide for the notation you see how
pretty they are how myself maybe SVD
hopefully without notation I will
present it there'll be no symbols on
this slide so I want I mean there are n
data points in D space rows above matrix
if you will I want you to think of the
SVD as just doing the following it's
finding the best stitch subspace of each
dimension right and best state in the
sense of squared perpendicular distances
minimize this is not least squares fit
where you minimize the vertical distance
you take the perpendicular distance to
the subspace Square it sum it over all
the points minimize it that's SVD okay
without symbols right and the most
beautiful thing about truth and beauty
of our SVD or linear algebra in general
is this I think I think of it as this
fact there's an algorithms person which
is a greedy algorithm works what does it
mean if I want to find the best that K
dimensional 100 dimensional subspace I
can find the best fit first
one-dimensional substitue online find
the best fit perpendicular there
perpendicular 100 times i'm time right
that is very nice fact which you can
prove which is elementary proof and that
i think is you know underlies sort of
the truth and beauty of it
historical surprise twenty years back if
you ask that easiest wasn't even like
army or anybody whether SVD would
actually scale up to modern data and be
useful we would have been surprised that
it could actually do that but it
certainly is one of the main tools now
they have scaled up and it's become very
useful and first reason is of course
that we have decades of very
advances in numerical algorithms that
have gone after or behind this then some
of it is our well-kept secret again we
saw petrels and Mike Mahoney discuss
this in detail over the week that in
fact linear algebra randomized
algorithms now play a role in numerical
computations so I don't want to discuss
anything any of these that is known I
would like to focus a little bit more on
you all I mean the numerical people have
principal component analysis
applications in mind I want to show you
some slightly different applications
that have come up in the recent past and
in these applications it's not sometimes
the algorithms that's new it's the fact
that we can prove that they do certain
things that in some sense there are
theorems behind them and the another
factor to know is one reason to do SVD
for instance if you're doing nearest
neighbor search you reduce the dimension
the problem was sitting in a thousand
dimensional space nearest neighbor cost
you a lot of time you reduce it to
hundred dimensional space you save time
efficiency that's not the aspect I want
to stretch because that's usually stress
perspective or we've heard about it but
of course there's another aspect which
is SVD can actually help not just in
efficiency in actually getting the
answer which otherwise wouldn't get and
I want to give you one or two striking
examples of this where SVD acts as if
it's a D noise or that what you throw
away was as if it was noise not
necessarily stochastic sense but we'll
see other sensors in widget with the
noise okay here I'll start with the
application of SVD modern application of
SVD if you will as I said the algorithms
here are not necessarily new people use
them as heuristics but the point is that
you can prove things wrong so here's a
standard object in statistics mixtures
of densities your case vertical
gaussians right in D space and it's best
to think of K as a constant K is mostly
a constant in this book and you have a
weighted sum of those that's the mixture
right and we will see one picture in the
next why
but right now bear with me so the idea
is I'm given polynomial many samples
from a mixture and I would like you to
learn the mixture
I'd like you to learn the components
under ways can you do that well okay so
as always in statistics right you want
to know how many standard deviations are
part of the means so if you have a
mixture of several things and the means
of sitting on top of each other to
gaussians there's no way you can tell
one from the other right
so you want a certain number of standard
deviations separation standard deviation
is the right unit and indeed we know and
this is a beautiful result of Impala run
naturalize it sounds it didn't come
without hiccups we this was several
years a word and several papers several
authors like this is in a way a
culmination it says if the means are
separated by a constant may be logs here
number of standard deviations then in
fact you can learn you can learn the
components now again it sounds natural
you say oh yeah sure but it's not so
sure here's a word of caution suppose I
say I'm going to learn by saying that I
take a point data point and take all all
it's sort of near post me data points
and consider them one cluster then you
will be wrong unless the separation is
much more than a constant number of
standard deviations we need D to the one
four standard deviations again I'll show
you a picture on the next slide which
perch is a nice picture to remember it's
very simple picture how on this way I
want to describe how a Swede is used and
again is very pretty and it takes only
four lines this is their father man they
argue to his argument take one component
goes into a spherical Gaussian and let's
look for the best fit line best fit
means least squares right let's deadline
for that Gaussian let's assume the
origin the mean of the Gaussian is not
the origin is sitting somewhere else so
here is a picture here's the Gaussian
spherical and here is the origin what's
the best fit line I claim just sort of
by studying at the picture the best fit
line is this best at one dimensional
subspace excuse me Lian going through
the origin one dimensional surface
it's this it's you can play around a
little bit and you'll see that that's
true I won't prove it but with it's very
simple to see so what now by symmetry
suppose I want the best ten dimensional
subspace the least squares fit ten
dimensional surface I claim any 10
dimensional subspace containing this
line does as well as any other and those
are the best okay and that's a simple
symmetry argument now I claim we have a
big coup on our hands because of this
why is that so
any K dimensional subspace containing
this line is the best for that Gaussian
that's true for every one of the
gaussians and therefore you take the
space spanned by all those K lines lines
joining the origin to the means of each
of those that subspace is individually
the best for each fi so it must be the
best for the weighted sum okay now I can
therefore find it because I know how to
find SVD I know how to find the best fit
subspace I find it and that subspace now
contains all the means and I project all
of the action to that I've reduced the D
dimensional problem to a small
dimensional problem that I can solve it
now I could have projected to any space
or a random space that wouldn't do
because if I project it to a random
space the means could come closer as
much closer as the data points and
that's no good because I'm measuring
inter mean separation in terms of
standard deviation they both fall by a
factor I'm not getting anything but here
the inter mean separation has not fallen
because I've gone to the space of
sentence right so you need I can project
and then I can learn now this was for a
mixture of spherical gaussians but
indeed okay so I should show you this
picture first but before that indeed
let's now come to this interplay between
TCS and statistics if you will so the
k-means objective function is just
minimize the sum of squared distances to
cluster centers so here I've shown you
two gals
the center's are here sort of
uncomfortably close and these gaussians
have standard deviation one in each
direction they are sitting in D
dimensions so there'll be route T's root
D Sigma away from the origin from the
center right okay now the exact
minimization of k-means np-hard so in
TCS we have spent quite a bit of effort
and in fact it is a total force that now
we have maybe 10 years ago
I love 10 years ago we have a constant
factor approximation that is we can get
we can minimize the k-means objective
function into a factor of two which
which was a good big achievement now I
want to ask you any takers for that what
does the situation say well the
statistician says the following here I
have two gaussians two spherical
Gaussian Xindi space these large the
standard deviations are Sigma in each
direction and the center's or 100 Sigma
bottom okay and you and your factor two
approximation k-means algorithm is that
going to do me any good the answer is no
because the mean squared distance of the
point is much higher than Sigma squared
it's D times Sigma so every direction
Sigma squared D directions such d times
Sigma squared and the errors of this
order D times Sigma squared which is no
good because you're only going you're
only allowed to make errors of the order
of Sigma squared if you were to
distinguish this from that so in fact
you could get most points wrong and
still have your objective function a
factor of two off so question
do we just throw away all these
developments from CCS the answer is
obviously no because otherwise I
wouldn't be saying it well see how to
use that so hopefully this picture is
actually simple very nice picture to
remember right sometimes one mnemonic
for this is the Sun and the planets or
what have you
here's the Sun we are really very far
compared to the separations you need you
extremely fun these very large tees in
the thousands that say well what do we
do for this problem so I'm going to now
generalize this the thing that when
father long did which is projecting
cluster to a model wait I don't know
where there's no stochastic model and so
you have n points in Rd I want to
cluster them into K clusters
I don't assume a stochastic model no
gaussians right we don't know that they
are gaussians now I want to say that the
main point of this slide is you should
not look at the k-means objective
functions you should look at a different
objective function namely the variance
of of the clustering so what's the
variance variance is what it should be
there's no stochastic model now so how
do you define variance well you just
define the max over all directions of
the mean distance clay to the cluster
center so you take a direction via unit
vector you take the data point to
cluster Center vector separating those
two take the square of the dot product
and I should have averaged that that's a
1 over n there are n data points now I
should have averaged this 1 over N and
it's easy to see that there's a spectral
norm of a particular matrix don't bother
if you did this is the matrix of cluster
centers it's just a spectral norm so I
claim this is a better quantity to deal
with then the mean square distance
suddenly for the Gaussian it is because
the the standard deviations were the
right thing to do but how about in
general okay so we asked can we find a
clustering with variance at most a
constant factor of optimal so every
clustering has a variance that's this
quantity I want to optimize that I want
to minimize that can I minimize it to a
constant factor like I did for K means
if the clustering I find like in that
process any good okay and then so here
here's why we didn't like here's why the
last picture failed this picture failed
because I had a simple generative
process of two gaussians I'm algorithm
did not distinguish them
okay which I should be able to which
were palawan for instance can right now
can we fix them and now what I want to
fix it more general so to find an
unambiguous clustering over clustering
where cluster centers are at least a few
standard deviations apart again it's
just a standard mnemonic from Statistics
means apart by hundred standard
deviations right has we had miss
forecasting well now we don't have a
stochastic model we have various without
that here's a clustering we find any
good so I'd like to say if there were
those two gaussians or any unambiguous
model I'll get it okay
is that true I'll nearly get it I won't
exactly get it the answer to all of
these is going to be yes right and the
algorithm is going to be extremely
simple and natural and again I want to
emphasize that heuristic aliy people
probably use such algorithms but the
point here is to prove that here's the
algorithm which is extremely simple
again you don't do your k-means in the
big space instead find the k SVD
substrates which is the best fit k
dimensional subspace if you're doing K
clustering project the points and then
do indeed now we will use the TCS
developments which is the to approximate
k-means clustering in the projective
space but not in the whole space of
predictive space okay so notice that a
projection saves me time because it is
lower dimensional but that's not the
fact that I'm going to use I'm going to
use the fact that the projection does
something which you do not accomplish if
you do the clustering of the whole space
namely it fixes that problem but more
generally than just calcium's so yeah
this theorem is there fairly simple
actually it's not very difficult to
prove so if there is an unambiguous
clustering there's a clustering with the
inter center separation or at least a
few standard deviations are clustering
this guy there's one fix that you have
to do but this guy finds it finds it
means only approximately a small
fraction of points could be missed
cluster could be differently clustered
they're millimeters so it finds the
gaussian case or any case when there's
an unambiguous clustering and in fact it
does minimize this hours or the
minimizer is also the variance to a
constant factor which is another thing
you wanted to do the cluster centers
found
here's an important point the cluster
centers found or within a few standard
deviations of the true centers okay but
you had an optimal variance clustering
that's a true sentence these are within
a few standard deviations now it turns
out so k-means is a one of the one of
the most frequently used algorithms and
one of the most frequently encountered
problems is that the starting centers
are no good so an example of a very good
example way where you have three
clusters like that and if you start with
three centers like this and you run
k-means you'll never get somebody there
you might get sort of you'll move up
somewhere there but you won't get
everything right make sure I want it
maybe the picture I wanted is two here
and one there in any case the spot is
very important this gives you a way of
starting with centers which are only a
few standard deviations support from the
true centers in fact I don't have no
other means of doing this we call the
Sun and planets picture if you just pick
data points for your stock which is
standard you'd be very far away every
data point is really far away from this
engine from its cluster Center so you
can't just pick data points and k-means
plus plus the various heuristics all of
them have this problem that you're not
guaranteed a good stop but this SVD does
do that right the as I said these are
not so difficult in fact a harder
theorem which we with Amit Kumar and I
were able to prove maybe about three or
four foxes ago is with this dot if
you're on the traditional Lloyds
algorithms that have exponential
convergence the distance to the true
centers false geometrically okay that's
that's a bit harder to do this as a you
get a good start doing this
so again it's what you would very simply
and naturally think of the point of
getting rid of other dimensions was not
just efficiency but it helped you in a
way that doing the whole thing doesn't
switch it's sort of the other other
dimension of somehow noise in this so
here there's no probability there where
where where or you think no no you're
off I mean so you are not clustering
epsilon fraction of the points right for
instance oh right so you don't get
everybody right and usually the fixes
people make assumptions about the
separation then you can get everybody
nice yeah
buddy
sorry
and just processes can come
yes so this denim is for just arbitrary
deterministic data no gaussians and but
you're off by epsilon fraction now there
are assumptions deterministic
assumptions that fix that that get
everybody right but their assumptions
right you don't expect to get everybody
right with our assumptions and I because
only give so the trouble of dynamic is
is you still could have a very small
cluster that's far away and you won't
get right that's actually the problem
here and then because it's not enough to
get every point right you have to assume
that every point has a property which is
which we call proximity which is that
it's actually a closer to its own center
than any event this you know you can
have a small fraction which are sitting
somewhere else and then you even be in
trouble yeah this works for
deterministic data as well okay that
actually was the first topic and I'm
going to move to SVD and constraint
satisfaction Alice Roy Barry oh yes sir
okay good question so let's get in so
there are be notions of what's called
stability and Frances knotty has worked
on it for the max cred problem now for
the clustering problem the stability
assumptions have generally said my
k-means objective function something
about it being 1 plus epsilon off and
unfortunately they failed for mm so the
traditional assumptions are stability or
so the the model of the story is don't
deal with the whole dimension
you must SVD you must project and they
deal with that so the what Swami at all
data and Avram blah manickam gupta all
have other notions of stability we are
all dealing with a big dimension and
they will fail the gaussian example so
this is actually in a way some notion of
stability the last slide with some
notion of stability it says that if your
optimal clustering is stable but you
must measure it in standard deviations
not in the whole space otherwise it
won't work then in fact you can find it
so another perhaps slightly I'm picking
examples of a speedy use there which you
might not have seen before it what I'm
doing so constraint satisfaction problem
max cut max case at max three side
satisfy as many clauses as possible
we'll see that SVD can help us here
let's look at max cut first max factor
you can formulate simply SS write a I
guess that Jason C matrix if you will or
edge weights if you have edge weights
excite exercise one if it's in the S
part of the cut it's zero vitsin be s
bar pot so s s bar edges or counted here
right and that's the quadratic form I've
written it in a way that perhaps linear
algebra SVD will be suggested by this X
transpose a 1 minus X you must maximize
over 0 1 rectus
that's np-hard of course but suppose we
have we find the best that matrix SVD we
do ke k rank if it so that now this is
spectral law
when I don't have a subscript I always
mean spectral mom which is the maximum
singular value of this matrix suppose
that less than Delta let's see how we
can use that to solve the maxcut problem
now instead of solving with edge weights
a let me solve with edge rate say K so
this is traditionally what you do in
approximation so here it's not actually
denoising but it's actually efficiency
so you project data down to the k
dimensional space and solve the problem
with these h weeks now since we have
this little inequality here so x + 1
minus X or vectors with norm root end of
next year 0 1 vectors root n is a norm
of each of them so you get an end there
but that's so for every X so the error
is at most Delta times n over all I'm
not saying anything very significant
here but if I can solve it with a K
instead of a are being good shape now
it's difficult or get that this Delta is
actually very small for certain matrices
in particular decency matrices of grass
Delta is really this small for a small
rank so the rank depends only on epsilon
and Delta is this small s that's a very
simple argument so if you did a sweetie
you would find this couldn't
approximation now it still remains for
us to solve the problem in a k right
this a K problem has been solved but the
why is that going to be easy so if K is
small K is constant I have a constant
rank matrix which is the age weight and
somehow before you look at this somehow
I used to have a full rank perhaps n
rank matrix and I have an N dimensional
problem n degrees of freedom I've come
down to K degrees of freedom K is
constant and now the general model to
think of in K in R K degrees of freedom
you can always do the problem
exponentially only in K and in fact
that's true I won't argue that in full
but let's pretend that we had a very
special k k equals 1 and our matrix of
edge weights actually looked like this
uu transpose
you're a symmetric right then what we
have to do we have
- do we have to do this maximization
from UI UJ x i1 minus XJ summed over
every all IJ no graph now all all AJ and
that's just actually you think about it
for a minute you see that that's just
splitting the indices up so that they
use some is about the same in the two
parts you do best if the sum of they use
in the one part of half the whole okay
and you can do that by dynamic
programming that's just said approximate
it's all approximate by dynamic
programming and indeed for general K
also you can do by dynamic programming
so in this sense somehow you know it
combines what is a traditional TCS to
all dynamic programming with SVD right
so to do this problem now it turns out
it's not just max cut you can do all max
to CSP problems this way only to a
certain error I mean the error is always
there okay so maybe I should I'm going
faster than expected are there any
questions to stop no yeah also we do
approximately because we are anyway
making an error in the other part
truncate the beds and do it for instance
now and rank case not very dissimilar
similar similar to that when K is
constant and you're still making an
error comes out maybe I don't know
whether I said that but it turns out it
solves not only this kind of it actually
solves problems where the way the
weights are metrics so here I say that
right so it turns out matrices which are
made of MIT this requires a little I
won't show this but if you have a matrix
just means triangle inequality finally
inequality is satisfied then the matrix
has a very good low-rank approximation
but after scaling you have to scale it
all
the state Minister so suppose I have a
master it's all their medical problem
with age we satisfying triangle
inequality then you can get a relative
epsilon approximation algorithm by you
doing this in polynomial time
I didn't quote but it's proved in that
paper that we roughly it is saying the
following right that I can scale the
rows it's it's not true that I just
approximate the original matrix
it won't do well I have to scale the
rows and after I scale the constant rack
approximation is very good and therefore
it's enough to solve that so all metric
to CSPs can be solved to relative error
by doing this process this is also
giving relative error for ten spots so
it's giving relative error for dents as
well as metric problems and there's a
common generalization of that maybe I
will write that so if you have a matrix
a fresh that sum over IJ should I
venture this because I forgot I I have
to refer to the paper it's been a while
but let me write this venture and write
this so let's see for dense matrices I
take the degree of high degree of J most
of the day while I'm allowed to put
sorry di plus the average degree VJ plus
the average daily average degrees around
this gets you N squared yeah so I think
this is right and it turns out triangle
inequalities metrics satisfy this and
dense graphs also satisfy this it takes
a couple of lines of proof to show that
metric satisfied isn't dense graphs also
satisfied that see via you can do all
that
it'll be exponential in K yes so yes so
it'll be exponential one over epsilon
but we don't expect to do in polynomial
time in epsilon for all epsilon right
so it would be exponential not to the
one our transcript there's been some
work on improving the complexity of this
but I don't know exactly where it stands
in fact I should mention that just as of
the last week's workshop a CMU students
name I forget now they can do the same
thing by going up the Lazare hierarchy
but it doesn't yet do new things and
they're trying to do that so there is
completely different technique for doing
this no well I mean I think they're
still trying to jump over okay so in
fact it turns out you can do all this
for tensors and that is perhaps
relatively new well I mean maybe new to
summer so I'll describe that in details
on that new actually it's somewhat
oldish paper by now but maybe you have
not heard about it so I thought I'd get
a chance to just talk about that okay so
let's for this talk only think of three
tenses although this whole thing
generalizes to all tensors things are
exponential in our reality of the tensor
so three tenses will just erase with
three indices right and by N by n erase
a rank 1 3 tents there is the outer
product of three vectors x y&z and I've
have entries X I YJ is that Cayley let's
call that right one the first lemma
which is not difficult to prove is that
I saw max three set or a max three CSP
in fact but max 3sat is a problem of
maximizing the number of three set three
clauses that can be satisfied
simultaneously right and that can be
reduced that can be written in the state
a IJ K X I and this second coordinate
would be 1 minus XJ and the third
coordinate also could be
their XK 1 minus XK there are 8
possibility cierra so it's a cubic form
right degree 3 and I'm going to
represent I'm going to talk of that as a
operating on X 1 minus X X / 0 1 vectors
so it can be formulated this because
that again is not so difficult the
second lemma is also not difficult but
the third thing is a theorem and more
difficult so for any tensor a there are
1 over epsilon squared Rank 1 tensors
whose sum has the following property is
a good approximation to a and that be
very careful the approximation is
inspection law but the error isn't
Frobenius norm
neither norm can be changed so you you
would do much better if I could put
Frobenius norm there cannot I do better
if I also put effect along there cannot
okay I have to do this so the spectral
norm is the maximum maximum muscle okay
I should write that Thank You max
overall unit length vectors multi linear
form allows sum over IJ K IJ K X I X I
YJ is that case this spectral norm right
so this lemma is quite easy you just in
fact you can just peel off rank one if
this is not true then you can peel off
the rank 1 tensor with high spectral
norm and keep repeating that that's all
so that lemma is easy but here comes the
interesting part this is hard so in fact
we can find in polynomial time but it's
exponential in 1 over epsilon we can
find in polynomial time four times that
may I think this should be just 1 over
epsilon skip four times that many rank
point pens this was some satisfies
exactly what we want
constructively right so again spectral
long for be nice for me otherwise we
can't do it and at the heart of this now
this this is like you're greedy right
for the SVD what did we do we peeled off
the top rank one component and then
repeated it greedy worked right you do
the same greedy but to do that we D we
have to do this crucial step which is
I'm given a tensor three terms together
it could be any arity I want to find set
of vectors XYZ unit length vectors so
that they approximately give you
spectral norm but I'm now allowed an
error with respect to the Frobenius norm
again we don't know how to big time
turns out if you can do the Frannie
matrix ok so I'll show you one slide on
how we can do it but we can do that for
any matrix any tensile okay so I am not
completely certain of the current status
of that I believe it's np-hard for four
tenses onwards if you want to do it
exactly now for three tenses there was
some issue whether it's true or false
but I suspect it's still np-hard even
for three to do it exactly
it's hard Hosford has some it's np-hard
for three also there are several
impossibility results that even some
definitions of Mago alright yeah
so I'm charting a path where you know I
can prove some English but it's true
there are a lot of things that don't
quite work and they're actually from
very nice recent papers of Moses
journalism okay so I want oh sorry yeah
this side of them will be randomized
okay I don't know there are several
questions with this that I don't know
the answer to okay
as I said this is maybe our result this
even ten years old but in some sense
there are several questions and
improvements that will be very nice to
have it I don't know but I want to
stress that this the point is you have
to do it for any matrix a right any tens
array so the worst case you know
sometimes I'm epsilon is in the exponent
which is a bad thing but okay so here is
the description okay so using that it
turns out that we can do relative error
epsilon approximation to max or CSV
problems for dents as well as something
called we call codons for want of
another word which is a generalization
of this sort of thing for tensors this
is for matrices and dips potentials that
is probably one it's more than it's it's
a matrix or a special case so for
instance power is a matrix also covered
by that also covers power matrix but I
think so actually a good question is
does it cover anything else interesting
I don't know other interesting things
that it might cover the conditions are
sort of like that but I don't know what
else it covers what are the classes
okay so one slight description of this
algorithm so Naaman maximization
pretends a spectral or maximization
approximate of course right we want to
find unit length vectors maximizing that
so observe the first one is just not
version if we knew the optimizing y&z
right then the optimizing X is easy to
find y I flood that y&z and I just get a
vector and then it's just a dot product
with X it's simple like this some kind
of MATLAB notations or some dot product
with X so then I can I can do that
that's not a problem so I you know I've
reduced the problem to 2/3 this problem
right I mean two of the three halves we
found
okay now observe that okay so if I knew
why inside this would have been the
optimizing X so this is the guy I want
to find let's write this out this is sum
over all J and K of a JK y jf K I want
to know the sum for my candidate Y
enzyme right before my optimizing y&z
but the Sun can be estimated if I have
just a few terms okay you have to worry
about the way it's what you have to you
can estimate it by knowing a few terms
but I don't know any terms of y&z let's
leave it aside for a minute but we want
to know how do we make sure the variance
is not too high
since the entries all disparate this
let's worry about that if I knew the
optimizing y&z and I want to estimate
distance or writing without then how do
they make the variance small now it
turns out and this of course I will not
prove it it turns out that it is
sufficient to pick coordinates for y&z
according to the squared length of the
entire flat of the tensor that you see
that requires proof that that reduces
the variance you can prove a variance
power so now I picked just a few J and K
samples and it's enough to estimate the
sum by those two in case I still don't
know the YJ YK
but they're just a few J&K so I
enumerate all possible values of y and z
to the ground I say let's say I have 10
J's and 10 case so have to know 10
values of y 10 values what's that but I
just enumerate them because the only 10
right I can do that then so this gives
us many candidate X's so each candle
while and that gives you an a candidate
X how do I know which is the best well
now I'm going to turn the problem on its
head so if I knew y&z I can find the
best set now I say I have several
candidates s if I know X can I find that
that's why is that indeed I can let's
just think of the value problem right
because I plug in X into this expression
then what I'm left with is a matrix
problem is one dimension less it's a
it's just top singular value for matrix
and now you know how to compute that in
general if I'm solving in our tensor
problem in the bowels of it I have to
solve many R minus 1 tensor problems for
every candidate and then I take the best
yeah so see I have to I'm on T I'm
wanting to estimate the sum by picking a
few J'son case only and somehow I have
to get the variance of the decimate to
be low for every possible value of y&z
all I know is that their unit vectors
and it turns out that if I pick J and K
with probabilities proportional to the
squared sum of squares of all the
injuries in that J's is one flat is
gives you a matrix in that matrix I take
the Frobenius norm squared and sample
according to that again square is
important then I will get a variance
which is not very big so I should say
that this kind of technique called
exhaustive enumeration really goes back
to very nice paper of our ACOG and
Karpinski maybe 15 16 years ago in which
they use that to solve some similar
problems like this and since being used
well I have used in many papers but it's
since been used so the point here is
what that you need only to estimate that
and then once you realize that
you sample J&K and then you don't even
need to know the wines that you just
enumerate all of them
okay so that actually more or less
concludes my SVD intensive stuff
actually there were some questions here
for tens less it'll be nice to know so
there are a lot of theorems known the
this train of thing I'm thinking of is
something that you can prove that you
can do a good enough approximation for
every tensor is what I'm interested in
so in that it'll be nice to know other
theorems better theorems you know
improved versions this other other ideas
it will be very nice to know we do know
a lot of impossibility it is also a lot
of those kinds of things but ok the last
vignette is something completely
different I just threw this up as part
of writing the book you know we had to
put in a turn off bounds and here we
come up with an interesting issue if
this is not such as much a sort of
pedagogical and not maybe I can run over
this unless there are questions I maybe
I should pause for what is the number of
seconds somebody's 6 ok well let's look
at it any questions I should have a lot
of content of bangles ok good so let's
see what I don't solve for instance you
could say that you could do something
iterative I have an X and I do the
singular value find the y&z and I put
them in and write I could do that what I
don't know is a proof that any of those
eels you a good result for every matrix
here's that here's the error bound for
every matrix which which is what I want
right somehow so for instance I mean one
obvious algorithm to do this is you have
a next candidate X you maximize to find
the wines that repeat yeah so you are
often yeah there is epsilon answer of
Venus norm of the matrix a which is bad
of course it's higher than spectral ma
but that's I don't know any lower con so
in other words you can ask what's NP
hard for approximation I don't know it
also be a nice question to solve
yeah what is hard and awake so if you
allowed never of epsilon times for Venus
mom this can do it but can you do better
or what's hard how well you can do
person it must be hard to do relative
error epsilon for spectral mom I would
think what I don't know oh well maybe I
mean you can do it in polynomial time NP
hardness I'm talking about right all
right well exactly huh spectral no we
can do it exactly right for matrices it
tends to three tenses yeah you think
it's hard spectral norm with relative
error epsilon NP hard
I don't know for sure but it could be
those could be interesting issues
okay so I think I'll just flash this
maybe okay so don't worry about the
symbols here but if you're teaching
Chernov it goes like this right
your iid mean 0 variance of no Sigma
squared and slightly different usual
statement then but absolutely bounded by
one I put in right because I don't like
that you'll see in a minute why then you
get tail bounce with your sub calcium up
to a certain point beyond that they are
also constantly so I don't care about
the constancy of phenomena but if you're
teaching a course very soon you have to
prove a similar result when they expire
Gaussian for instance we are proving
Johnson Lyndon Strauss you have to prove
this video Gaussian of course this goes
out of the window because you don't have
absolute bounds right and you sometimes
have to do a puzzle and exponentially
and so on so forth the moment-generating
function exists but only for certain
lambdas they don't exist but here is a
theorem which is true which applies to
all of these situations right and I
presume it's folklore but the proof is
not very difficult it does involve a
little combinatory ok so you can replace
the absolute bound by moments now the
point is the moments can grow as s
factorial but not Sigma to the S it's
only Sigma squared so so channel
I mean Bernoulli random variables don't
the moment bones don't follow Sigma to
the S they only follow Sigma squared
because they have really have heavy
tails so it turns out that that is true
and that gives you all of these counts
right I don't know why I put this up
because I was just working on this is
the last few days but it probably does
well usually you need more than finite
moments but maybe it does follow I mean
you should fall from something more
sophisticated but I want like a
half-page proof right probably follows
from
the the pest I mean the exchangable I
mean certainly would follow from moving
oh okay so that's all actually the talk
but there's one sort of open problem
that I wanted to state which I didn't
put up on the slides so all these
randomized algorithms all in algebra
right prove results when the sample size
is small now I'm going to say constant
but you can do a little bit of it what
would be nice to prove is you take a
matrix you pick some rows but your
sample without replacement well let's
say you sample a constant fraction of
the rules
right this is an old problem that we are
worried about in practice is what you
might do right you will have 100,000
Road matrix you don't want to settle
only hundred rows of it you want to
sample maybe 5,000 so you don't have
very good results for that range that I
think would be a good challenge to I
mean sort of big challenge to tackle but
for example one thing is that the
results we have or patrols in my can all
have more recently any all of those
results right when the number of sample
rolls tends to end you want the error to
be going to zero yeah so that would be a
problem to tackle
yeah I mean the whole thing type of yeah
yeah yeah so so but but like they prove
that sampling what is it have things
usual unique or sampling without
replacement and the other one right but
the other one will end up requiring this
one over epsilon squared sort of kills
you because it tells you you have to
take N squared samples to get the error
to zero which you want them I mean you
want to say that I picked point A then I
get equal yeah so the application of
without replacement with replacement may
be off by xscape I mean that kind of
question all right
you know I'm I don't have another half
an hour's worth of materials so somebody
needs to talk who would want to talk
there so let's see if nobody has
questions now okay I can start pointing
to people and say do you have a question
oh we can go on early fall right it's
not a bad thing to do so when our first
workshop is in next week
lunchtime meeting where there's already
lined up well good okay that's the only
formal activity that I'm aware of and
then the week after we have a we have
the workshop now we they might have fit
in through all those talks we can drink
there no I mean as I said being streamed
and so on yeah I think I'm done I mean I
don't think